deira I was really taken by the stark
statement two-thirds of the way through
the comments you don't make deals with
your friends how much of an enemy is
around to the American people look I
mean Iran is one of only three countries
left on the US list of state sponsors of
terrorism now that cube has been taken
off that list so by far it's considered
one of our biggest adversaries but the
president made very strongly the point
that as he said you don't make deals
like this with your friends and he
compared it to former are armed
negotiations with the Soviet Union so I
think the the message he has tried to
make clear all along as this agreement
is not based on trust it's based on
verification and that he believes that
all the options that he has now IE
military force will still remain open to
him if Iran does not abide by its side
of the deal indira the President did say
in this phrase stuck out for me that if
should Iran fail to live up to the terms
of the agreement sanctions would snap
back into place is it as easy as that is
that an automatic movement or do the
negotiating partners have to agree well
we've gone through a copy of the text
that we obtained today and there are
several mechanisms laid out for
snapbacks one is with regard to UN
sanctions there's a very specific
process which is sort of like a reverse
veto so it means that if the United
States or anyone else thinks Iran is
cheating on the deal they can simply
refuse to continue the suspension of
section that's how that works from the
point of view of the US and the European
sanctions yes they can snap them back if
they believe and have proof that Iran is
not complying the question would be what
other countries go along with our
secondary sanctions at that point I mean
it would depend on the world community
and whether they believe that Iran was
in fact cheating under the deal if the
US asserts that they are so a lot of
that will come down to un monitors the
International Atomic Energy Agency and
what they say about Iran's compliance
remember none of the sanctions relief is
going to come until at least December
15th Iran has complied with all the
nuclear curves plus they have to answer
questions about past military dimension
and hear a thank you so much at folks
Greg value a of Potomac research
through publishing moments ago and he
ben says no words about it the
opposition and cross-party opposition
within Congress will be substantial to
the steel